when you're a brand I think that a lot
of people are starting to finally have
the right conversation which is like
cool I got eight thousand trillion
quadrillion impressions and like did I
really sell more body spray because of
it right look the more that we can be a
beacon to conversations around actual
business results and not reporting
headlines and awards we will end up
being historically correct and that
being said I think the best way to get
those results is to make branding and
marketing content not D our content I'm
a sabotager this exactly you're not
supposed to do
no really can you'll be doing the wrong
thing above you drop your knowledge but
I also want to like it took us a while
but what you just said yes I might come
up in different yes I know
respect Ben listen to this real quick
I'm gonna text you an idea
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Taurus will make the vlog to vlog I feel
it I feel the next chapter I feel like
when we for [ __ ] like when we forced
we're gonna get better at YouTube come
this September forced I feel in the last
three days like I'm ready to break some
patterns like and it feels great I can
like feel it we have the meeting on
Friday with the whole team of like yo
like a morning all of you shits coming
down and and I think that's why I did it
and I think that having fun with your
audience and doing something nice in
turn how are you welcome such a pleasure
how are you are you very good
so masterminds like I'm not and you're
what's your opinion for those that are
going to be a fact check them look if
people get value they get value like
like I don't listen I don't think I
deserve to judge anybody about anything
I Spit my truth and then everybody
decides what they decide like I don't
think I'm better than anybody I don't
think that I am right I really don't
like I buy $150 huh
I bought this how much this cost me buck
fifty I bought $150
Jets Jersey that is each row suzuko 's
name Suzuki's name on it cuz he made fun
of Tom Brady I would argue that that's a
stupid you said $150 but it means
something to me and so I don't have any
interest in judging if somebody pays
some guy or gal $50,000 a year to be in
their mastermind and they think that's
valuable cool I just think we're in a
very interesting time or there's
unbelievably meaningful content for free
at scale and that's something worth
debating you know I can't get that for
free I think a lot of stuff that I heard
in these masterminds or look I'm
unbelievably typically cynical about
somebody who's never made money and any
other way than telling people how to
make money
[Music]
always you thought you were perfect
so did I ain't nobody perfect Who am I
I'm a good person over five nobody oh
[Music]
[Music]
you're the best this from brain and
Warneke my best friend in the human
world at 8:04 a.m. Sunday morning I know
this this to me and Tyler I know this
sounds crazy but ever since my kids
discovered the backpack kid they are
hooked on Gary's videos with him and now
Gary's content in general but because of
the language I don't want them to watch
this morning air and his daughter
went into a tantrum because she couldn't
watch Gary life is insane
there should be an edited version for
kid hustlers Tyler replies we have
censored a ton of it
friends like really awesome would love
it bottom line is I just wanted you to
know that it's funny I want to launch my
YouTube kids channel time at wartime we
Sean's in the office you have no idea
right but I had
[Music]
you just purely bring the audience value
you're putting you're putting things in
the bank
this second regardless I hate when I
have a new book or a sneaker out means
I'm taking out of the bank you ask you
can say whatever you want about
authenticity and this and out you
there's asking and there's giving my
preference is giving attention is
[Music]